[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
happy thursday
[Applause]
richards bringing the betting expertise
every week
is aaron dolan from fanduel and the man
of the people many people
from coast to coast that is greg ivory
welcome to you both
lovely to have you here with us each
week in our chuck vs america segment
we go toe-to-toe with sir charles and
last week
charles barkley and i bet on jason tatum
to outscore bradley beale
uh america took bradley beal and america
includes
uh aaron and greg uh and jason tatum
he just put up he just put up a 50 piece
a 50 piece to bradley fields 20 yeah the
game
so chuck more importantly chuck
gained one on us in the standings in
chuck versus america let's take a look
really yeah we are we're 11 and six and
charles
charles barkley is ten and seven so the
race is tightened
but all that matters is that we are
clinging to this lead
and greg is still clinging to his
handy-dandy ipad
oh i'm not letting this thing go it's
it's me in the ipad we're working
together
you cannot do that i i know kevin we got
off to a big league i thought it was i
thought we were running away
i thought like what are we doing america
come on let's let's let's let's get in
line
let's tighten up a little bit and uh
let's let's let's show
chuck who's boss uh but yeah like you
say this the ipad
i love the ipad it's not going anywhere
this is the handy dandy ipad if you guys
do not know this is how you get your
hoodies
i am in the comments cabbie i'm in the
comments giving away hoodies
uh i see i see
pboss 21 p boss 21 saying let's go a lot
of fire emojis
excited for the show shout out to you
also deep
geek is back deep geek is back shout out
to d
geek why not d geek you're walking away
with a hoodie today
uh cabbie that's it for that's it for
the comments that's it for the
conversation all right
we're gonna get them warmed up because
we have a bunch of great basketball
games to get to tonight
uh and we're also going head-to-head
with charles barkley again
this evening as you know charles is
famous for his guaranteeds
and he's issued his biggest one of the
playoffs
take a look i love giannis's movement
without the ball
they're not just giving him the ball at
the top of the key they're going to
sweep the miami heat
oh does that need to go on the wall hit
the button hit the button right there
hit the button
hit the button the button is right there
hit the button
[Applause]
all right man
you're wrong the heat sweep the heat
a bold proclamation and you guys know
how these these things go
when charles barkley guarantees anything
absolutely hammer the fade button i
think he guaranteed
uh that charlotte would win and i
believe indiana as well and this
the playoffs have only been you know
it's like game three of the playoffs and
he's already over two
so uh we asked you on social everybody
will milwaukee
sweep miami uh the miami heat it's game
three tonight
uh the last time the heat was swept was
2007 to the chicago bulls ben gordon
lewalding and the boys so
america is voting 59 yes
that milwaukee will complete the sweep
yeah so there's a lot of confidence out
there uh this week is special because
fanduel is offering a barkley super
boost
if you agree with chuck that my my that
milwaukee will complete the sweep
these they're boosting the odds from
plus 200 to plus 350.
it's the barclay super boost that's
pretty dope it's free money from fanduel
so we appreciate you and always salute
you
um uh g-money have you ordered any of um
jimmy butler's big face coffee because
miami needs a boost
and i'm sure some of the people in the
in the comment section also need a boost
as well as yourself
i need to boost your bets too bro we'll
get to that
uh fresh fresh off fresh off a win fresh
over parliament women anyway
that being said uh cabbie uh
i've not ordered any jenny butler's
coffee
if you if you want to send the order my
way thank you brother uh
but let me again let me ask the artist
let me ask the audience
do you think milwaukee is going to sweep
miami get in the comments let me know if
you think so i need
broom emojis to fill the comment section
if you don't
get creative tell me no uh aaron
what is your take what is your take how
do you think the series will turn out
so after last game obviously it looks
like that's possible but the bucks had
those two games at home and absolutely
that was an advantage they're looking
like they're out for revenge now this
series is heading to miami and if
the bucks were going to or excuse me if
miami was going to take one game
it would be this game in particular i
believe just because if teams go 0
and 3 in terms of the series they're
going to be eliminated 100 of the time
even if they do get to a game seven so
this is a very important game
i think they'll be able to step up and
just in terms of the buck sweeping
obviously
great odds but just personally i don't
really like it i actually like bucks
four and one plus 170 on the panel
sportsbook
jimmy butler has never been swept in his
career and i'm sure he's not planning on
starting a trend
in this series the miami heat shot 50
5-0 three-pointers in game one and they
forced overtime
i say they reopened that playbook like
go back to volume shooting it worked for
you
literally two games ago so you're back
on south beach you're in the comfy
confines
of your of your bed and your home gym
light it up
so i i listen miami has excuse me
milwaukee has more talent and they will
likely win the series i'm predicting 4-1
at plus
170 just like you aaron uh but i don't
think it's going to be a sweep
the the heat are gonna get one of two on
south beach and
if it's not tonight in game three then
it will be in game four
just like last year when miami was up
three nothing
the bucks won that fourth game and then
they were they
had a gentleman sweep out of the bubble
so i don't think the
uh milwaukee bucks will sweep uh the
miami heat g-money what's what's what's
your take on
this particular series and does anybody
agree with chuck
that we're gonna see a sweep in this
series
cabbie to be honest i'm seeing a lot of
sweets oh yeah
comments interesting seeing a lot of
sweeps in the comments
i see jessie bolanos yes they will sweep
giannis is on a
mission giannis is on the mission shout
out to you
jesse you were walking away with a
hoodie uh
hold on hold on dodo bird says dodo bird
one says
bucks bucks in six
jimmy got some buckets in him jimmy got
some buckets in him shout out to you
dodo bird
uh outstanding here we go here we go
here we go hold on hold on
ryan ray ryan ray says sweep cabbie ryan
way set ryan ray
says sweep shout out to everybody that i
just named you were walking away with
the hoodie
uh my take my take cabbie i think it's
gonna go six no sweep
no sweep i think it's gonna go six miami
has a team full of dogs
i i've said it last year if you guys
don't know they just got beat by whoa
like 4 000 points whoa kevin
i mean come on man they got dogs but
they just got they got mollywood
they got yeah i mean you're not lying
you're you're spitting straight facts
what you're saying
you're spinning facts but there's still
there's still some dogs on that stuff
in the tank especially buckets yeah yeah
yeah he just like my guy
my guy said he has some buckets left in
him jimmy butler has some buckets left
and
bam has some buckets left in them duncan
robinson
kendrick they have buckets left cabbie
so that being said i think they can win
two i think they can win two
out of uh i mean they think they can win
two
in the sixth uh in this game and the
series is going six
gotcha that's what i was trying to say
there it is uh uh a salute to dodo bird
is like
dodo birds extinct like greg ivory's
winning tickets anyway america uh check
out inside
the nba uh the pre-game show on tnt for
charles barkley's picks
and if you're riding with them make sure
you get on fanduel
and bet the barkley boost so uh
it's our it's our favorite bet of the
year it's our favorite bed just in
bedding period it's
three by two uh and the question is will
there be two three-pointers made
in the first three minutes and we're
asking for either game tonight
milwaukee in miami or phoenix
in los angeles will there be will the
3x2 hit in either game
so last week both three by twos hit and
one squeaked out at the last second take
a look
if they're gonna have a chance to win
michael brockton like
he's not as slow-mo as kyle anderson but
he's just so calm with it
and salute to you pj watched him from
the corner money
that was an early hit center position
his bike yo evan fournier wears
like a defensive ends number and this
spark
yes oh that was so close like you saw
the ball
enter the the cylinder at the nine
minute mark
and fanduel granted that a win so salute
to everybody at fanduel
uh and thank you marcus smart for cash
and uh that three bye
two uh g money which match-up do you
and the winners-only army like tonight
cabbie let me talk to him really quick
let me talk to him
hey guys get in the comments let me know
let me know
talk to me through the comments which
3x2
should rewire which 3x2 should we ride
should we rock with milwaukee in miami
phoenix la you guys let me know aaron
which way are you leaning which way are
you leaning are you are you leaning
towards south beach
or are you uh liking those vibes in la
in the palm trees definitely leaning
towards south beach i mean the bucks
made the most threes in the first half
in franchise history
in their last game going 15 of 29 from
three-point line
they're obviously lighting it up i know
miami was not great shooting 29
from the three-point line a positive
regression baby plus
obviously they're gonna have to start
out quick quick to make sure the bucks
don't jump out to that lead so i'm gonna
go
with the milwaukee heat game you know i
like the second
the second game in the doubleheader in
the staples center tonight i subscribe
to the next man
up theory and since chris paul is
battling a shoulder
shoulder injury we're not even sure if
he can do this like he can get his arm
to 90 degrees
so the next man up is cameron payne he
was excellent in game two with 19 points
three for seven from downtown so i think
because phoenix
is is a it's the rare two seed but the
underdog in the series
they have to play with some urgency and
the pressure is on la not phoenix so
these guys can go out and shoot with
ease so that's devin booker that's
mikael bridges
and that's cameron payne so give me the
three by two i'm not saying it's gonna
be only
the suns um hitting some three-pointers
for uh
in the first three minutes you know a
kentavious caldwell poke might get it
done might get one in
uh might shoot one uh for the lakers on
the other side
because lebron was in his grill like
your boy draymond green and kevin
durant's grill
and just urging him to shoot because
he's got so much confidence in him so
three by two sons lakers kcp
campaign devon booker that one's gonna
hit
g money which game do you like tonight
for the three by two
and which game does the the army in the
comments section
like to lock in this evening
cabbie aaron i'm seeing
a lot of uh i'm seeing i'm seeing both
games actually
okay i got heat bucks i got heat bucks i
got
phoenix lakers shout out to you nash
your walk away with a hoodie aaron
aaron's doesn't steve nash out the game
today it may it might be steve nash we
don't i don't know
aaron uh tristan aaron tristane uh
phoenix la d book shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
i i see deep geek in here talking about
the miami milwaukee game shout out to ud
geek m go blue and go blue miami
milwaukee which game robinson g
i'm giving the people hoodies oh my bad
my bad one more
jake jake jake leston jake leston
jake lesten uh phoenix la sorry cabbie
here we go i'll give you guys what i
what i'm thinking
i'm gonna last week i threw the vibes
out there cappy it through the vibes
that
you know both three by twos were going
to hit and guess what
they both hit i know we had a little
controversy at the end
we had the little controversy it was a
little controversy at the end
on the last three by two if it went in
at nine minutes 8 59.
guess what guess what the vibes
the vibes the vibes pushed us through
pushed us through with a victory anyways
what i'm saying cavi
both of the games look at both of these
games take the yes on both of the games
but if i had to choose one if i had to
choose one
milwaukee miami there's a lot of
shooters on the court cabbie there's a
lot of shooters on the court duncan
robinson duncan robinson
miami they always run this play early
cabbie
aaron they try to get duncan robinson
open early they like to let it go
early i'm rocking with them i'm rocco
with miami
i'm rocco and milwaukee they also have
shooters so give me that game
if i needed to take one but take both
i take both all right take both games in
the 3x2 and
make sure you check out uh br betting's
social channels for the link
to the 3x2 offered by fanduel listen
tonight will be the first playoff game
inside the staples center for the lakers
since 2013.
so you know the place is going to be on
fire the capacity is about seven
thousand seventy five hundred so not a
full stadium
but it will be rocking phoenix faces the
lakers in game three
and this is the thirteenth time that
these teams have met in the playoffs
we wanna know will king james register
a triple double tonight g-money
the staples center it's gonna be lit is
lakers nation in the comments
and which way do they which way are they
betting braun to get a triple-double
or nah lakers nation
laker nation are y'all in the comments
are y'all in the comments
uh hey y'all tell me y'all let me know
if y'all think lebron's gonna get a
triple-double i need to see lebron
gifts in the comments right now laker
nation you guys let me know but aaron
it's your time to shine right now
because i want to know i want to know
straight from you yourself is lebron
james recording the triple
double tonight or or no so i'm going or
naw
i don't think he will i mean he's
averaging 21.6 rebounds 10 assists in
the last two games against the suns but
he's only had five triple doubles this
entire season i totally get he's going
to be in the staples center
he's going to be amped up but i honestly
it's great odds plus 600 but i feel like
there might be a reason
they are so high so i'm actually not
going to take him to have a triple
double tonight
listen he's he's back on his home court
which will be wild the last time they
he did play at the staples center he did
get a triple-double which was against
golden state in that play-in game
the stakes were different there's
there's not the same urgency tonight
and phoenix has a much better defense
than g-money's
golden state warriors so i'm saying no
for a triple-double
tonight for king james uh g-money which
way is the audience leaning
cabbie i'm seeing a lot of no's not
gonna lie but
i don't know if it's at froy or aunt
i'm gonna just call him aunt ant's pro
he's in the comment repeating his
comments so shout out to you aunt though
but
uh i i see a lot of no's i see a lot of
no's i actually see some yes here we go
giving away hoodies jake lesten you
already have one shout out to you you
can walk away with another
r more r more shout out to you he's
rocking with lebron to score
a triple double tonight uh motivated
motive aided is also rockaway
to record a triple double tonight um
cavi i don't think he is me personally i
don't i i don't think that lebron is
going to get a triple double tonight
reason being i don't think lebron's 100
percent to be on it
he did ball last game tabby i'll give
him that he did ball
last game but i just think that ankle is
like 85 percent
i don't think it's 400 so i'm gonna say
no
to lebron getting a triple double
tonight but i do think the lakers will
ball i do think lebron will ball but
triple double uh i don't think so it's
it's been nice to see him and anthony
davis
have a lot of chemistry and cohesion
like they did
in game two but uh if you guys want to
bet on the triple double that
option is available to you at plus 600
very juicy odds
you know we love our same game parlay
around here and this week
fanduel is hooking it up all customers
get a risk-free 10
same game parlay bet each week during
rounds one
and two of the nba playoffs so
um to make sure you you guys get the
best
betting advice possible we've gone ahead
and
benched greg ivory
[Laughter]
because we we just need to review his
ticket from last week hey
okay hey i'm a man of the people i am a
man of the people cabbage and you're
hitting the side
every time this ticket this ticket this
these bets
were given to me and i was you know
trying to relay the message
come on nick it's okay yeah that's right
okay
washington hey in their last game
hey hey hey hey it's it's it's okay it
it means
we're so confident in this what you do
though i remember i was being like yeah
we
were like this besides the jason tatum
under
we were i i feel bad i'm not gonna lie
i need to be on punishment so you know
i'm gonna go sit down yeah take some
time to recollect myself
and uh hand hand the baton off to aaron
i mean
i mean so i'm gonna try to step in and
give you guys a good same game parlay
let's let's get it let's let's let's
have the expert uh
speak facts and speak a ticket uh into
into fruition into existence fruition
here winning tickets
yeah so what do you got i went with the
underdog parlay here so i went with as
good of odds as i could possibly get you
while also making sure that i think
players be able to hit this my first
thing is the heat money line i actually
think
they are going to win this game if
they're going to win any game it's going
to be in south beach i think they win
this one just because the bucks
sometimes
they get so excited when they get a huge
win that they kind of
have a negative regression there all
right also dante de vincenzo to record
eight plus rebounds plus 220.
he's averaging eight and a half over the
last two games also
dante divincenzo over three and a half
assists plus 130 he's also
averaging over this number in his last
two games so that was two great ones in
terms of just getting juicy odds like
we've talked about on the show
duncan robinson to score 15 plus points
plus 120 he's averaging
17 in the last two games so let's take a
look at those odds because i tried to do
my best to give you as
big of a bar light as i could possibly
give you although
plus 3 000 yeah those are legit you are
an optimist aaron i mean
you are like you just we're going for
long shots here but we need to
wow i mean dante di vincenzo eight
rebounds
when giannis is out there roaming around
and bam out of bios roaming around and
lopez is there i mean that's that is
optimistic
for it duncan robinson 15 points
that dude's got a hit seven these four
triples
in the last two years we'll see that's
what he's done that's what he does
that's what he does cabbie he shoots
that thing i wish you luck so
uh what greg what does the audience
think of this ticket this
four legs they're probably ripping you
ripping me apart
uh yeah i mean the audience is showing
aaron love
they're showing aaron love shout out to
frank uh yeah
they they're showing aaron love and and
and they think that
i mean i'm i'm going to speak for them
and i'm going to speak for the people
i'm going to speak i'm going to speak
vibes for this parlay
i hope it hits aaron sin advised for you
uh
the vibes need them yeah positive vibes
a lot of good vibes
hope it partly hits i don't really have
anything that i don't like on it
that's being honest so hope you hit and
the people they're
they're they're backing it they like it
cubby all right so we got some positive
vibes and good vibes good luck i mean
that's a that's a long shot plus three
thousand it is
but hey if it if it uh if it hits then
you will have a very nice you will enjoy
a very nice weekend
there in philly so yes
exactly uh thank you so much for tapping
into the group chat live in the bleacher
report app remember what you learned
today swing for the fences
and same game parlays with those role
players
check out fanduel for more info on how
to on how to bet the barclay boost
and to build a risk-free same game
parlay
and lock in your calendars we're back
next thursday baby for another edition
of the group chat alongside aaron dolan
and greg ivory my name is cabbie
richards and we are leaving the group
chat
based have a great weekend be safe and
good luck everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you